I had your number from the moment that
you set foot in this town you have been
nothing but trouble General Hospital
star Jacqueline ziemann has died
years old
General Hospital executive producer
Frank Valentini shared the news on
Twitter Wednesday writing that he is
heartbroken she was a bright light and
true professional that brought so much
positive energy with her to work he went
on to add that she will be greatly
missed but her positive spirit will
always live on with the cast and crew
hey Carly hey hi
you were a million miles away just now
yeah I have a lot to think about
that's why I'm here my daughter needs
and I am here for you
Jacqueline's played Bobby Spencer on the
popular daytime soap opera since 1977.
what about us what about you what about
me what about little tiny vulnerable
Mike we are all in danger you know she
starred in over 880 episodes and was
still portraying Bobby until the time of
her death a great big heartfelt thank
you to the very special people who have
been watching us and supporting us and
keeping us on the air all these years
we love you she also played Bobby in the
TV movie spin-off series General
Hospital twist of fate in 1996. Stefan I
just need some answers
surely you can understand
and appeared in several other shows
including One Life to Live Chicago Hope
and the bay Jacqueline is survived by
her two daughters singer Rick
Springfield who famously starred on
General Hospital in the early 80s I knew
this was going to happen
from the moment I saw your eyes
of that surgical mask in or
shared a tribute with ET on Wednesday
saying he's incredibly stunned and
broken-hearted adding that Jacqueline
was a truly kind soul with no touch of
the diva love to your spirit as it
ascends sweet girl you left your mark on
many of us and you will not be forgotten
[Music]
foreign